afraid to return home more than 20,000
civil war refugees have been stuck four
months on these United Nation grounds in
Juba the capital of South Sudan UN
soldiers and police work around the
clock to protect them from further
attacks German Development Minister Gant
moola finds a tense situation he wants
to talk personally with refugees and aid
workers so what can be LC well you see
this game is terribly ibaka led to the
refugees depend on outside support but
the international aid organizations have
limited means the camp has a shortage of
water food shelter and medication the
hopes placed in the minister are great
the refugees don't dare return home till
the violent power struggle between the
forces of South Sudan's President Salva
Kiir and those of former vice-president
Riek Makar has ended can German soldiers
help here it is Katia nueva man da team
admitted we are discussing only mandates
with military options and we are
dramatically neglecting civil assistance
that he fit is mullah opposed to sending
more German soldiers the head of the UN
mission sees things differently I think
if there was one time that robust answer
on contributions from member states of
the United Nations is needed it is now
we really are in need of any support we
can get both of staff officers that you
have many of in the mission and are
doing a great job and and of deployment
of troops shortly after get molesto
clear words with head of state Sybok
here since the beginning of internal
conflict in south sudan germinate has
been temporarily restricted to emergency
aid before i was the precondition for
further development is an end to the
hostilities between the various parties
as she didn't peptide molly the
minister's second stop was also recently
a scene of fighting most of the country
is meanwhile at peace and german
development cooperation has resumed
money from germany helped organize this
community's administration a new water
tower provides fresh drinking water for
all residents the community takes the
official visit from germany as a reason
to celebrate and the minister joins in
when he visits an agricultural research
and training center the students proudly
show him their harvest gap Milla grew up
in the countryside so he feels in his
element here I grew potatoes when I was
a boy too now the man from the Bavarian
countryside wants to foster agricultural
projects in Africa he knows that better
living conditions mean fewer conflicts
he and Molly's minister for rural
development sign plans for a new
research cooperation students from Mali
and Germany will now be able to continue
their education in each other's
countries Milla is convinced that
projects like these are the best
approach to long-term development listen
Mia we have to invest more in
development infrastructure and education
Kostabi kiddin that's what I've seen
here in models that fantastic projects
on site and dementia do shots when
people have the chance to get an
education and training then they can
develop their country alumna and then
wars and crises become a thing of the
past the [ __ ] head on
the German minister has made a lot of
friends in Mali now he has to gain
support from the German government for
his strategy for Africa